[Music]  461 MEP s backed Ursula Vonda Lions team  of commissioners after she presented her  program and goals the new Commission  will take office on the 1st of December  MEP s adopted two draft resolutions  calling on the EU to adopt net zero co2  emissions by 2050 securing the EU s  position as a world leader in the fight  against climate change  this year's cop 25 kicks off in Madrid  on the 2nd of December Parliament  approved the 2020 budget after getting  an additional 850 million euros for  investment in climate action innovation  and youth oleg sentsov was in Parliament  to accept the 2018 Sakharov Prize after  his recent release from a Russian prison  the Ukrainian filmmaker continues to  fight for the release of 314 Ukrainians  still imprisoned in Russia to animate  xcos film God exists her name is  Patricia won the 13th edition of  Parliament's Lux film prize